menchú fue entrevistada en un acto
promocional en shanghai para los juegos
olímpicos de invierno de pekín apareció
junto a la ex estrella de la nba yao
ming cuando un periodista de singapur le
pregunto ella negó haber sido agredida
sexualmente y
ante todo debo subrayar que nunca he
dicho ni escrito nada acusando a nadie
de haberme agredido sexualmente ese es
un punto muy importante eso contradice
su denuncia del 2 de noviembre las redes
sociales de que el ex vice primer
ministro chino zhang a all y la había
obligado a mantener relaciones sexuales
en varias ocasiones tras esta acusación
la ex campeona de dobles de wimbledon y
el abierto de francia desapareció de la
vida pública hasta esta sesión de firma
de autógrafos el 21 de noviembre lo que
pone en duda su libertad de movimiento y
su seguridad la preocupación se extendió
por todo el mundo incluyendo la onu la
casa blanca y otras estrellas del tenis
la asociación femenina de la disciplina
reaccionó el domingo a su declaración
seguimos pidiendo una investigación
completa justa y transparente sin
censura sobre su acusación de agresión
sexual la asociación de tenis femenino
ha suspendido todos los torneos en china
incluida hong kong ante la preocupación
por payne el hecho alimentó las
peticiones de boicot a los juegos de
pekín el ministerio de asuntos
exteriores chino ha dicho que el caso se
exageró maliciosamente